all right let's okay so now we are
looking at daemon daemon Blackfyre
daemon Blackfyre Blackfyre leading the
charge at red grass field by jose daniel
cabrera
pena so this is a character from sort of
deeper in the history of the two garyun
dynasty and he is I think I thought got
this right looking at thing he is
Danny's great-great-great-great
grandfather you see he would know just
like that I don't think so actually
because he's daemon Blackfyre right
that's what you said David right
forehead to red grass field the Black
Forest were usurping line right they
were they were the sons of I'm sorry
he's not he's great he's the he's a he's
a bastard claimant to the throne yes of
Danny's great-great-great
great-grandfather sorry right
Aegon King King Aegon the fourth also
known as Aegon the unworthy had a lot of
bastards he was a he was a horny guy and
everywhere he went he he fathered
children on serving wenches and tavern
girls but also on the daughters and
wives of noblemen and he only had one
well he had he had a had one son by his
legitimate wife who was also his sister
in the Targaryen thing and that was his
legitimate heir but he didn't actually
like that kid very much and he likes
some of his bastards better and he was
you know he was not a popular King Aegon
the unworthy that probably gets it from
his name and he made a lot of trouble
for Seven Kingdoms because on his
deathbed he legit
all of his bastards and then that
created a question of okay now they're
legitimate and I bastards where do they
fall in the line of succession and the
one of the oldest bastards who was a
splendid you know look like a Targaryen
great warrior charismatic handsome he
gave black fire which is that ancestral
sword of Aegon the conquerer and all the
Targaryen Kings and he presented the
sword to to his son who was the warrior
son they the the son who was the crown
prince was not much of a warrior so and
sometimes he was giving a sword to this
on who was best fit to use it but that
created the issue well does the sword
represent the kingdom was he saying this
son should be my heir
he was unclear on that point and when
you're unclear on that point in the
Middle Ages you not only got a war to
clarify the issue and indeed that's what
happened here a gun and his supporters
rose up or Damon and his supporters rose
up after after Aegon's death against his
half-brother Darren and there was the
first of Blackfyre rebellion and it was
followed by four more Blackfyre
rebellion because daemon Blackfyre
fathered children of his own and there
was a whole nother line of pretenders to
the black fire pretenders that
periodically would come invading
Westeros and say no no it with
legitimate kings and they would try to
overthrow that Targaryen and this was
all after the dragons have dined out so
in the days when they were dragons the
tag Aryans might have been able to deal
with this a little more easily but
without dragons it's all a question of
who can raise the biggest armies and who
can win the support of the powerful
Lords and the populace etc so they're
just questions of succession has
or just don't well not completely
continuous throughout the story but it
comes up again and again it it's
obviously very reminiscent of the real
historical events that you've talked
about being an inspiration the Wars of
the Roses we're similar not so many
bastards but but similar arguments about
who is entitled to be the king yeah I
mean that's you know a large part of
ancient history in medieval history is
is devoted to these succession crises
you know the the nation that could
actually manage to get us its laws and
its succession in in something
approximating smoothness tended to
flourish because they didn't have a war
of regeneration when when a king
succeeded his father but there were
always issues that weren't really quite
clear or where they thought well this
person has a claim but this person also
has a claim so which claim do you you go
with and you see that in English history
too